[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour ce
nouveau numéro de cette ut le journal
nous sommes mercredi 12 octobre voici
les titres
les rencontres de la sécurité ont eu
lieu ce matin en préfecture de
versailles l'événement a permis au
public de découvrir ou de redécouvrir le
travail de ces femmes et hommes au
service de notre protection hier soir à
l'estac à l'école d'ingénieurs de
montigny-le-bretonneux près de 500
personnes eu la tête dans les étoiles
grâce à michel tonini un astronaute
français qui a partagé ses expériences
dans l'espace avec le public et puis
vous découvrirez elliott un labrador
100% écolo qui impressionne aussi bien
soumettre gymnase que ses voisins vous
découvrirez pourquoi dans ce journal
on débute avec lui la 10e université des
mairies qui s'est déroulé aujourd'hui au
centre sportif les pyramides à
port-marly plus de 450 maire accompagnés
pour la plupart de la radio ont
participé à des réunions et des
conférences sur les anges du département
les élus ont pu également échanger avec
des entreprises du territoire et coûté
leur réaction au micro de michael et
demi d'eau
c'est l'occasion de pouvoir rencontrer
ce non seulement des collègues mais
aussi
[Musique]
des membres d'assemblées comme
l'assemblée départementale
voir nos collègues députés sénateurs de
pouvoir parler
vous avoir eu
rendez vous
que ce soit au moment du
déjeuner de l'apéritif du déjeuner
et de pouvoir évoquer des problèmes qui
concernent nos villes c'est vraiment
intéressant ce chien charge des
questions de mobilité et de transport et
comme vous savez si c'est des sujets qui
intéressent beaucoup de monde on est
honnête au carrefour de l'état de la
région du département de communauté de
communes de près c'était donc on a
besoin de rencontrer du monde et de
savoir un peu ce qui se passe dans
l'actualité
l'académie 2-2 versailles célèbre les 30
ans du bac pro aujourd'hui créée en 1985
ce bac à l'horaire est devenu le premier
diplôme de formation professionnelle
près de 200 jeunes loups validé dans
l'académie depuis sa création pour
l'occasion un forum organisé aujourd'hui
et demain au palais des congrès à
versailles
régulièrement nous croisons des
policiers des gendarmes ou encore des
sapeurs pompiers mais connaissons-nous
vraiment leur métier les rencontres de
la sécurité qui ont eu lieu ce matin
devant la préfecture de versailles ont
permis d'en apprendre un peu plus sur
ces femmes et ces hommes au service de
notre protection anne-laure l'anguille
un chien après un sachet de drogue une
interpellation à cheval le sauvetage
d'une conductrice pour cette nouvelle
édition des rencontres de la sécurité
une vingtaine de policiers gendarmes et
pompiers se sont pliés au jeu de la
démonstration mais pas seulement ils ont
aussi tenu à expliquer étape par étape
chaque opération
une centaine d'élèves et quelques
dizaines de passants ont assisté captivé
aux exercices ce qui n'a pas manqué de
réveiller chez certains leur fibre
patriotique c'est une immense à la fois
fierté voilà que notre pays soit
performant dans toutes ses actions et en
même temps oui une immense admiration
pour que ces hommes et ces femmes qui
sont vraiment au service quoi pourtant
les relations entre les forces de
l'ordre et la population ont connu des
hauts et des bas ces derniers mois la
manifestation intervient dans un
contexte tendu après la tacc des
policiers dans l'essonne mais selon un
récent sondage 82 % des français gardent
une bonne opinion de la police le but de
démonstration c'est de rapprocher la
population des gendarmes des policiers
des pompiers à travers des commandes des
opérations dynamique ce qui permet aussi
à la population de se rendre compte un
petit peu des différentes facettes de
notre métier lille doute que la
manifestation aura suscité des vocations
s'engager c'est avant tout faire preuve
de courage et de dévouement c'est en
tout cas le message clair qu'on voulu
faire passer les organisateurs de cette
journée
sans qu'employé du château de versailles
ont été mis en examen aujourd'hui pour
escroquerie en mode en bande organisée
et faux après avoir vendu plusieurs
milliers de faux billets à des touristes
depuis le mois d'août les suspects
écoulé d'être éthiques et réutilisées
selon l'établissement public le
préjudice s'élève à 250 milles euros
parlons de santé à présent une réunion
d'information sur le don du sang de
plaquettes et d'organes était organisée
hier soir au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
cet événement organisé en partenariat
avec la caisse primaire d'assurance
maladie des yvelines et l'institut de
promotion de la santé a permis de
répondre aux questions sur les démarches
à suivre ou encore les besoins un
reportage de michael et demi d'euros et
de patrick jacques de dixmude à
faire connaître le dos médical c'était
l'objectif de ces intervenants de la
santé ce mardi 11 octobre au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
alizée en partenariat avec la caisse
primaire d'assurance maladie des civils
et lee ps l'institut de promotion de la
santé la réunion d'information était
centrée sur le don du sang de plaquettes
et d'organes je crois qu'il faut c'est
comme une porte il faut il faut la
pousser un peu plus facilement et est
sans cov s'engouffrer dedans
c'est donc effectivement faire connaître
des sites fixes qui sont les nôtres
parce qu'on a beaucoup plus de mal pour
recruter les donneurs c'est important de
faire connaître au public
la loi aider les problèmes que nous
rencontrons aujourd'hui dans les
yvelines le don d'organes est effectué
dans les hôpitaux de poissy saint
germain en laye de versailles la réunion
d'information a permis de clarifier la
loi sur ce sujet méconnu du grand public
la loi dit que nous sommes tous des
donneurs présumés et donc si on est
opposé au don d'organes ou de tissus de
son de son vivant il faut vraiment le
dire on peut aussi s'inscrire sur le
registre national des refus et si on est
pour on peut prendre une carte mais
légalement ça n'a pas de valeur donc le
plus important c'est vraiment entend
parler à ses proches à sa famille parce
que c'est vers eux qu on se tournera si
vous arrive quelque chose pour savoir si
vous vous étiez d'honneur au point en
france 6000 greffes d'organes sont
effectués chaque année pour environ
20000 personnes qui sont sur liste
d'attenté les donneurs peuvent effectuer
un don sans limite d'âge
hier soir à l'estac à l'école
d'ingénieurs à montigny le bretonneux
près de 500 personnes ont eu la tête
dans les étoiles grâce à michel tonini
astronaute français qui a voyagé dans
l'espace il a partagé ses expériences
avec le public la conférence était
organisée par la commission héros
nautique de l'aéro club de france avec
l'association des stack a space odyssey
un reportage de mélanie poker
[Applaudissements]
des décollages spatiaux il en a connu de
michel tonini est l'un des neuf
astronaute français avoir été dans
l'espace en 1992 vers la station mine
avec un équipage russe dans un vaisseau
soyouz et en 1999 sur la navette
columbia mais tente en orbite le
télescope chandra dans le premier vol
russe était à un rôle d expérimentateurs
scientifique médical avec principalement
une expérience sur l'échographie et sur
l'expérience neurosensorielle alors que
chez les américains j'étais plutôt un
ingénieur de bord pour le déploiement du
télescope chandra c'est un sentiment
assez étrange parce que vous voyez la
terre d'une façon particulière comme on
l'a gérée vue vous voyez les étoiles
avec tout en couleurs vous voyez toutes
les étoiles sans aucun frein
atmosphérique ou nuageux vous voyez le
ciel est noir vous voyez des planètes
comme on les a jamais vus pilote de
chasse pilote d'essai astronautes il est
aujourd'hui président d'une école de
pilotage à étampes michel tonini va
aussi à la rencontre du public amateur
et passionné pour la plupart étudiants
très intéressant on a appris beaucoup de
choses parce que c'est vraiment une
personne le métier d'astronaute c'est
quelque chose qu'on voit pas tous les
jours c'est à la fois un rêve mais c'est
vraiment le domaine dans lequel on
travaille et c'est notre c'est notre
métier en fait ici une très belle
expérience alors c'est quelque chose de
très spécial parce que déjà c'est pour
moi un rêve d'enfant pour aussi je pense
beaucoup de monde
parmi les étudiants qui y ont assisté et
c'est quelque chose qui non seulement sa
motivation mais aussi permet de voir le
comté le côté vraiment concret de ce
métier parmi les 450 auditeurs peut-être
de futurs astronautes le 15 novembre
prochain un dixième voyage un français
partira en virée spatiale
et si votre chien devenait écolo et bien
c'est le cas d'elliot le labrador de
gildas son animal de compagnie ramasse
depuis cinq ans tous les détritus qu'il
trouve durant ces balades une passion
qui lui est venue naturellement et qui
impressionne ses voisins nous sommes
allés à sa rencontre
reportage de camille lambert et de
patrick jacques de dixmude à
[Musique]
ramasser les déchets dans la rue une
passion pour elliott depuis ses deux ans
du haut de ses quatre pattes ce labrador
traque les détritus lors de ses balades
quotidiennes
c'est venu des armes en tant qu il a
commencé par une bouteille il ya
quelques années en plus ça a continué en
s'aggravant si on peut dire s'aggrave en
ramassant plus de choses et pour lui
c'est une passion maintenant tous les
jours de ramasser le maximum de charges
et de l'érable une
[Musique]
bouteille en plastique emballages pizza
ou paquets de cigarettes vides tant
qu'il peut attraper elliott récupère
tous et pas question d'abandonner son
trésor sur le chemin là encore les un
rituel il va s'arrêter normalement
devant le conteneur et devant le
conteneur il va tout lâcher là je peux
vous montrer qu'il lâchera pas tu peux
toujours et c'est tiré aucune façon il
agira tout ce qui vient tous contribuer
il était arrivé à la maison qui va
accepter tout lâcher pour avoir eu
un comportement écologique qui attise la
curiosité à 7 ans l'animal est devenu
une star dans le quartier ça assez
intelligent notre notre notre chien du
voisin je pense que c'est une bonne
chose mais bon c'est dommage que des
gens qui jettent les choses comme ça
dans la rue c'est pas bien et lui a dit
sera contrainte à un chien quand même
que les gens font n'importe quoi voit
tous les jours elliott accompagne
également son mettre au travail dans le
cadre de la police de l'eau cette ruche
n'a pas fini de nettoyer nos années
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis prochain journal
demain à 18 heures bonne soirée
[Musique]